[Music]
and tonight as predictable the media mob
is having a full-on meltdown one after
another amid classified Biden documents
now being left in multiple locations
here to join us and give us his take he
is the host of the number one show on
the weekends life liberty Levin also
nationally syndicated radio show hosts
number one best-selling author
all-around good guy I call him the great
one thank me God bless us uh Mark I know
you got a lot to say on this
um I want to start with your thoughts
overall on the money part of it which is
breathtaking to me
well the money part of it is is the name
of the game with the bidens isn't it
um did you see those homes that Biden
has on a senator's salary it's
incredible it's got an Oceanfront home
and Delaware has got this big mansion in
Wilmington he's got tens of millions in
the back on a senator's salary that's
pretty good but what I want to get into
is what's taken place here this is a
major Scandal why
because the Department of Justice tried
for two months to cover this up
that's what you see in the timeline
nothing leaked from the FBI nothing
leave from the prosecutors nothing got
to the media until Monday this week and
I'll tell you why in a minute
so they find the documents November 2
who finds them the private lawyers that
is bizarre everybody says so and they're
right what's the magic date about
November 2 and why are lawyers going and
looking for documents then we know
November 9th the FBI begins an
assessment well why didn't the FBI go in
from that point and search that office
go into his homes and search his homes
issue subpoenas they did none of that
then we have November 14 Garland assigns
John Laos the U.S attorney in Chicago is
on his way out to perform an initial
investigation now he does it awfully
fast did he give him a timeline did he
say 30 days 40 days 50 days what was it
meanwhile they muscled through the
midterm elections without a leak during
the cover-up four days later they
appoint a special counsel this Thug this
Democrat who prosecutes a
genocidal war criminals they appoint him
as the special counsel's families all
loaded up with politics up to their
eyeballs on the Democrat side
and of course they do that without ever
mentioning that they're looking into
this Biden situation with the U.S
attorney what next December 20
almost seven weeks after the initial
batch is found they find another batch
of documents in Joe Biden's garage how
the hell did that happen why didn't the
FBI investigate and look at his house
for God's sakes they're there in plain
sight then what happens January 5th last
week one week ago the U.S attorney
excuse me is uh the U.S attorney January
5th he has his report all done
for Merrick Garland so it sits there for
a week whether or not to appoint a
special counsel mayor Garland didn't
need this U.S attorney to do any kind of
preliminary review
so January 12th one week today he
appoints a special counsel why because
now they find another document the the
private lawyers bring up another
document this was a cover-up and you
know how it got blown because the
Republicans got elected and they still
were going to do a cover-up and I'll
tell you when it ended Monday when there
was a leak a a intentional planted leak
about documents they only mentioned the
office building then Tuesday NBC
mentions as they put it out well there
is another batch of documents it's
because on Sunday
Mr Comer the incoming chairman of the
house oversight committee Sunday night
on my show when I asked them
specifically about the National Archives
you have oversight are you going to dig
into this and see I said every president
every vice president every attorney
general and Secretary of State unless
they can demonstrate otherwise has taken
documents including classified documents
home and not return them if I'm wrong
prove me wrong and they should all be
looked at whether it's Obama or bush or
Cheney or Gore or Clinton because
they've all done it now that said he
said yes we're going to look at
disparate treatment well they didn't
want the Republicans to find this out so
they had to put out some information so
it's no accident that 20 hours later
they leaked this stuff now the National
Archives When Donald Trump specifically
accused Obama of taking secret
information and other information they
came to Obama's defense what did they
say no no no 30 million they've turned
everything over to us we're in charge We
own it uh lock and key and everything
out they lied
these documents are Obama administration
documents
the documents they have in the office
the documents in the garage the
documents and Biden's Library
the National Archives didn't have those
we have no idea how many classified
documents to this day that Biden has
what about the unclassified documents
did he only take classified documents
with him to this moment the FBI has not
investigated all these properties to
look for information that we're aware of
not to this moment why because Garland
wanted to keep this hidden he wanted to
sweep it under the rug until it got hot
the Republicans were calling hearings
they were going to call witnesses and
then Garland reluctantly today appoints
a special counseling who does he appoint
he appoints the right hand man to FBI
director Christopher Wray that's hardly
the same kind of special counsel that
Donald Trump is facing so this whole
thing stinks to high heaven now it's
rope-a-dope no lists of people who
visited the Biden home in Wilmington
where he kind of hung out most of his uh
most of his vice presidency Beyond no no
lists that could be used for nothing now
it's going to be the White House
spokesman said we take this very
seriously we take this very seriously
now we have a special Council
investigation I'm sorry we can't look
into anything I'm going to tell you this
if they dare to charge Donald Trump for
what took place and there was no
obstruction of justice by Trump or his
people they were negotiating the FBI cut
it off criminalized the process and went
after him if they do that the nation
will be furious
done that's it
all right that's why we call him the
great one Mark Levin hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else